let's look at the clock and see what
time is shown the clock has two hands
this first shorter one which represents
the hours and then there's a longer hand
here that represents the minutes so we
can start with the hours this shorter
hand right here before we can figure out
the hours you may have noticed our clock
is not labeled so let's add some labels
at the top of the clock here is always
12 o'clock that's where the hour hand
starts and then the hour hand really
only deals with these larger square
marks so when it works its way to this
first one then it is now one o'clock and
when it gets to the next one 2 o'clock
and 3 & 4 5 and so on
until we work our way all the way back
to 12 o'clock so now our hour hand let's
look at our hour hand right here we can
see it's just barely past the 10 but it
hasn't reached 11 so that means our hour
it's after 10 o'clock maybe 10:05 maybe
10:30 but it hasn't reached 11 yet so we
can safely put a 10 in for our hours and
now let's switch to minutes here's our
minute hand and it looks like it's lined
up to this little mark minutes are
shorter and they also use these shorter
marks on the clock minute hand starts
facing up so when the minute hand was
here it was 10 o'clock and then it moved
1 minute so it was one minute after 10
or 1001 and 1002 1003 1004 1005 so this
is 5 minutes after 10 and it keeps going
1006 1007 1008 1009 1010 right here and
maybe you can see this pattern it keeps
going here it was 0 minutes after the
hour so 0 then 5 and 10 so this one is
going to be 15 we're going to keep
counting by 5's
and then one more minute after that is
16 so it is 10 16 or 16 minutes after 10
one more here let's again start with our
our hand and we know our labels we know
this is 12 1 2 we could keep labeling
but our our hand is facing right there
so we really don't need to our hand is
between 1 & 2 so it's after 1 but not
yet - so it's 1 something and by looking
at our minutes we can see it's quite a
bit after 1 this minute hand has worked
its way around and remember this is me 5
minutes after 10 15 20 25 30 35 40 we
can't go to 45 that's too far so let's
go back to 40 and now just count by ones
41 42 43 44 our minute hand lines up
here - 44 minutes after 1 o'clock or 144